welcome oops hey welcome yeah and I'm
not able to move Johnny ballgame Johnny
ballgame from the US maybe you Father
Kings Indian fianchetto way again or
let's see maybe it can also be a
symmetrical no I place the panel
variation with 96 hmm i don't really
know what's what's the most topical
moopheus this age 3 b3 all kinds of
stuff I tried some years ago I tried to
learn this yeah when Morris of rock the
famous is really a theoretician made his
books I try to to learn this line
without much success the fianchetto
Kings Indiana mean something like that
though is I believe a theoretical
continuation and now be five or
something else I have seen something
like that so it's at least probably not
far off from the main path is playing
quickly though
jam probably F takes c6 well maybe I can
also no it didn't ok threatening to take
on c4 so I probably have to take them
and now maybe oopsy one yeah Black has
some central pawns here e 6 d 6 possibly
can play see 5 or something like that
but the the dangerous that he also has
weakened some squares it's a it's um
sometimes that white can attack the the
pawns with the pieces White has a
healthy peace development both both
bishops fianchetto would something like
95 maybe I can can be an option now or
let's say H 694 oh this moves I
completely overlooked not that it is so
so much of a problem maybe but should I
pledge form interesting maybe
ok it's just dropping back
you
we kept difficult position and I would
like to play 95 but it's simply not
possible maybe here try to to also open
up the rookie em I'll move like d5 is
weakening the structure enormously
that's a very committal decision giving
up the the bishop i don't i'm not sure
what is ideas he needs to have some very
concrete idea with with the oh yeah i
can i can just take it takes
yeah probably Queen d3 was also
interesting very tough tough to deter I
should go afore really efore Queen g4
would be nice yeah let's do that it
limits the the night very much and now
Queen g4 would be a good move but he
plays probably no Queen d7 I techie 5
and Quincy 8 looks awkward getting into
the sea file so I'm threatening Queen g4
him gaining very useful a very useful
spot for the Queen hmm he's attacking
this okay let's protect it for the
moment it's not so much the pawn that is
irritating but if he takes that my
bishop hangs and it's not assessed it
does not have any good square uh-huh ok
so I'm going here this was the idea
anyway Queenie six and possibly a form
the right moment yeah his aha here he
can go Quincy aid yeah probably just
take it an f4 just just a good end game
and I can prove this a player for
anywhere the point is he cannot really
cover you five and I'm threatening both
to take and f5 so yeah and now the
bishop is oh I can play Bishop f6 now
Bishop f6 okay this is a 3 hangs
possibly
not sure about the strongest
continuation I can also push the f
partner f5 takes f6 it just got nine f5
that's not so great can push here time
morning
tough it's probably a good position for
white but it's tough to play become a
bishop strong but I'm not totally sure
about the the right continuation I will
look that you can cover it with the a
true creator that's not so great
45 seconds no I just have played played
some wrong move I don't know what
exactly was wrong but I am I certainly
had a very good position there
not sure why you gave up the porn check
Brooks is seven check out check check
check check check check check check ah
bloody time yeah i was losing long time
anyway I'm just to slow him white for
things haha yeah I don't know I'm just a
slow in the scam here was ok i mean it
it was a very mysterious and game play
by him here just is just a pawn doubt
then he gave up c6 for no reason and yet
now step by step like it's just she just
lost ok i did have any time to calais it
properly intact from a technical point
of view with here what is of course just
winning I should push the Acorn really
but it's tough to play I'm really am
with any sort of plan when you have 14
seconds against 19 check just a 405 and
and and it's it's over and here was just
making hectic moves basically I should
try maybe will be five maybe I can can
get them get the rooks exchanged to
secure the draw yeah this is the right
decision
time time wise but um yeah it's um it
was interesting though because some yeah
it always feels a bit a bit strange if
you look at this position always right
going to use that it's really here this
was a very interesting spot hmm yeah
what is the right continuation wyd
really should have something because of
this long-range bishop and this f5
possibility the computer wants to play
Bishop deformer that's also not very
convincing this is also not convincing
yeah maybe I must do that after all this
is the computer line nor the computer
gives me 5 which I find hard to believe
to give like this blockade with King is
6 know this that sets a strange computer
eval maybe yeah maybe the problem is
that f4 is too early here the computer
suggestion is very strong kingi to King
g2 in itself is not nothing great but
the computer wants to play prep moves
kingi to be four and then f4 and then
it's very strong the problem is that his
night is completely out of play it has
no square to go to absolutely none and
after a four I'm breaking up the long
diagonal and have the clearly better
minor piece and so f4 was just um just
badly timed or let's say lesser you are
not perfectly timed as here it's a bit a
bit bit strange I don't really have a
gray move here
I originally intended this but it's not
helping that much as there's always a
three hanging as the compensation for
the hanging porn in the center hmm okay
thanks for watching